Hello, uh, I am Tom Hiddleston
and
I would like to give you a
tour of the set of The Essex
Serpent.
♪♪
Our story...
(Banging noises in background)
(Chuckles)
Just hold, hold for a second.
♪♪
Tom Hiddleston:
Our story is set in Victorian
England
Tom Hiddleston:
and split between London and
Essex.
♪♪
Tom Hiddleston:
We spent the first seven weeks
of principle photography
Tom Hiddleston:
on location with our chill
heaters and our wellies,
trying to dodge the tide.
♪♪
It's been a lot of trudging
through mud.
Battling the elements has felt
like a contact sport.
Tom Hiddleston:
The Essex landscape is going to
be absolutely stunning.
♪♪
Tom Hiddleston:
In Essex, we needed a very
wintery atmosphere.
Now that it's springtime, we are
inside filming our interiors
Tom Hiddleston:
on a soundstage in Enfield.
♪♪
What is amazing about a set like
this, is we're in North London,
the real house was in Essex.
Tom Hiddleston:
But as soon as you walk in here
you're back in the imagined
world of where the story takes place.
This canvas that you see that
wraps around the set,
Tom Hiddleston:
actually has projected upon it
the exact photographic
replication of where we were in
Essex.
What I love about this, is this
is where we had our chickens
Tom Hiddleston:
and Dixie and Ryan and
I decided to name all the chickens.
Tom Hiddleston:
Ryan wanted to name one of them
Jeff.
I don't know if that's relevant,
but I thought you'd like to
know.
Forgive me, these are rather
unreal gardens.
♪♪
This is Will's study.
Will is the vicar and the
reverend of Aldwinter.
♪♪
Tom Hiddleston:
On this desk, there are all
sorts of texts
Tom Hiddleston:
that represent Will's faith.
There's a psalm book, the
enormous bible on the side there.
♪♪
On this box there's a dragon
with a snake's tail
and maybe that's a depiction of
the Essex Serpent from folklore.
♪♪
This one I love. Will has a
spaniel called Pup which I have
a soft spot for.
And the art department, they
gave me a matchbox with a
little spaniel.
(Chuckle)
Don't know if you'll see it in
production but
at least I know it's there.
♪♪
Tom Hiddleston:
As an actor, it's so inspiring,
cus you walk into a space
you've imagined the world in your mind
Tom Hiddleston:
but it's been built for you.
And all you have to do is
inhabit it.
Tom Hiddleston:
It's a real gift from the
designers.
♪♪